[Applaudissements]
suite isabelle non mais je n'en mets je
vous jure j'ai lu un truc sur wikipédia
est-ce que vous avez déjà lu votre wii
qui peut dire non alors là je préfère
pas un non mais oui c'est un truc de fou
alors on apprend que vous appelez
isabelle suzanne bosque oui c'est vrai
ça oui d'accord vous avez vécu dans la
campagne savoyarde
non non que votre maman sol est né au
brésil
oui ça c'est voilà paulo et elle a vécu
18 ans ryo au pied du corcovado donc
voilà et lorsqu'on va en bas de votre
pack dans notés référence
on apprend que vous auriez lol le plus
cher d'europe quoi c'est que cette
histoire ait de bronze mais je vois que
ça hein parce que non mais sans rire
c'est votre vrai wikipedia l'oeil de
verre deux verres est histoire
complètement con mais non mais regardez
c'est le vrai wikipedia belmahi beau
c'est une histoire de fou harel de verre
posée aux 93 suite un accident avec un
tigre dans un parc animalier c'est vrai
mais n'importe quoi mais c'est vrai que
ce soit vers à une valeur pécuniaire
énorme
il coûterait 260 15000 euros et lloyd
vers d'isabelle morini-bosc vaudrait
aujourd'hui 4 à 7 fois le prix d'origine
ans gamal corey non mais c'est vrai
cette histoire va un gag mais je vous
jure créé d'autres frais wikipedia va
laisser ça des spectateurs en même temps
c'est incroyable vous c'est que c'est le
problème de wikipédia n'importe qui peut
écrire n'importe quoi sur la page de
tout ça c'est très très fort ces cas là
il faut sûrement wikipedia d'ailleurs
parce que c'est vraiment celle
d'isabelle ces fous complètement
ah mais ça alors ça c'est qu'en
maintenant à part le fait que j'ai
travaillé dans un parc animalier c'est
tout tu savais jamais eu un accident
avec un tir canon annonce et apprécier
le confort moi j'ai confiance et au
mythique ayant mal apprécié son sommet
il avait pas porte bien avec les ting
n'aurait jamais film conan doyle à un
million d'euros
il a causé la rochelle du verre et
apporte autant et il s'y trouve que de
la poussière de diamant à la confection
précise ultra mini maîtrise et le
quartier du vert quasi improbable
aujourd'hui c'est super pressante mais
un grand merci est magnifique et je vous
jure et celle de votre frère wikipedia
garantir le bon de montrer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas un label à c'est totalement
faux et ben écoutez pas très bien alors
je note c'est bon je me suis dit à un
moment je ne savais pas ça fait plus de
dix ans que je connais je ne le savais
pas